هناك دراسه امريكيه وجدت بان المال يطيل
عمر النساء فاعطوهن المال لعشنا اكثر لكن
العبره في التفاصيل صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
نشرت البحث الذي وجد رابطا بين التحويلات
الماليه الى الدول الفقيره وبين معدلات
الحياه
الدراسه جدا طبعا وشملت
السبع تاثير التحويلات النقديه على معدلات
الوفيات نحن بدورنا هنا بحثنا عن اجابات
وتوسعنا في موضوع المال والنساء في العالم
وعن قدره النساء على الادخار مقارنه
بالرجال
[موسيقى]
كيف يؤثر المال على نفسيه المراه وبالتالي
صحتها ويجعلها تعيش اكثر
حقيقه المال يؤثر على جميع البشر يعني
اصبح عصب الحياه اليومي
والاقتصاد العالمي والاقتصاد
الدولي اذا يعني تعتبر تحضر الدول او ينسب
تحضر الدول الى حجم
اقتصاده وحجم اموال ومدخل الفرد ايضا دخول
الفرد اليومي فيها ومصروفه
فلذلك
يعني يتبع هذا الامر المراكز الصحيه
والصرف الصحي يعني المصروف على الصحه
العامه للانسان لذلك هوايه امر ضروري يعني
ما بيحتاج دراسه اكيد لحتى انه نعرف انه
هو عصب الحياه وشريعه وهو يطيل عمر
الانسان فعلا اطال عمر الانسان نتيجه
استخدام هذا المال في الصحه وفي العلم وفي
التطور وفي الطعام وتحسين نوعيه الغذاء
دكتوره يعني ماذا عن المراه نفسيه المراه
اذا هل هي ايضا تنزعج وربما اكثر من الرجل
اذا لم تتمكن من ادخار المال من جلب المال
يعني
ما العمل قلق من نوع جديد يعني يمكن صار
عنا اضطراب جديد هو القلق على جنين المال
لان الاموال المال والمصاري هي الرمز هي
عامل رمزي
لتعويض اشياء كثيره في
نقص نفسي او نقص بالحياه المراه اذا الرجل
اعطاها وقال لها روح السوق هل تسعد بذلك
دائما طبعا بهذا يعني حتى في عنا علاج
علاج الاكتئاب الشوكي
انا على فكره
يوميا تقريبا معروف فالموضوع هون يعني له
عده اوجه الوجه الاول ممكن يكون صحيه اللي
هو انه المراه بحاجه الي تعيش حياه جيده
من مستوى ماده جيد لتقدر تعطي بشكل جيد
وحتى في مقوله شعبيه يعني كانوا جداتنا
يقولوها
بينصحونا فيها الاجداد اللي هي انه عطي
البنت اكثر من الشب انه انت صرفي تكوني
كريمه كثير واغدقي على البنت بالمال
واحرمي الشب الصبي لانه البنت اذا
اعطيتيها هي حتنتج اشياء حتتعلم
حتوفر
لاولادها حتفكر بعيلتها حتاسس للشيء ثاني
بينما الشب اذا تضايق ماديا راح يروح
يشتغل راح يفكر انه يزيد تعلمه راح يفكر
يسافر رح يفكر يجني مال اكثر طبعا كله
بحدود يعني هاي مقوله شعبيه ولكن نحن
بعلميا بنحكي بانه الاثنين بحاجه للمال
والاثنين بحاجه لحياه كريمه لانه الحضاره
فرضت هذا
والحياه هذا العنصر
[موسيقى]